[Musique]
ce voyage commence au nord du liban je
suis à quelques kilomètres de la syrie
ce pays qui depuis huit mois
vie loin des regards c'est ici en terre
libanaise que je recueille les premiers
témoignages
première halte cette école aujourd'hui
elle abrite des réfugiés syriens dont
beaucoup d'enfants
ils sont plus de soixante dix à vivre
ici ils en arrivent par petits groupes
toutes les semaines
[Musique]
je regarde leur jeu sans trop comprendre
puis je me rends compte que ces enfants
rejoignent scène qu'ils ont déjà vécu
tous me disent avoir pris part aux
manifestations
certains ont été victimes de la
répression
nous nous sommes les manifestants 2 nous
sommes les miliciens du régime et les
militaires il nous frappe c'est comme ça
on les fera pas ce qu'ils veulent la
liberté des enfants en première ligne
dès le début de la révolution la torture
de trois d'entre eux dans un
commissariat va déclencher le mouvement
de révolte en syrie
des enfants qui avaient l'âge de haïfa
que je rencontre ce matin j'ai 13 ans
[Musique]
vadocz et ils m'ont arrêté à la sortie
de l'école un barrage ils m'ont frappé
ils m'ont bandé les yeux
ils m'ont enfermé dans le coffre d'une
voiture
on a roulé 45 minutes ils m'ont jeté
dans une cellule qui sentait mauvais ils
m'ont arraché les ongles
ils m'ont torturé à l'électricité
je pleurais je leur disais que je
n'étais qu'un enfant et plus je disais
ça plus ils me frappaient
ils m'ont tout pris tous mes droits je
ne suis qu'un enfant aucune loi
n'autorise la torture c'est dans cette
série où la violence semble sans limites
que nous allons tenter de rentrer
clandestinement
[Musique]
allez voir de l'autre côté tenter de
comprendre
j'ai rendez vous dans un hôtel avec un
homme qui pourrait nous faire passer la
frontière
il se présente comme l'un des leaders de
la révolte de la ville de homs
devenus le haut-lieu de la contestation
son nom de résistant
7 abu farès a beau faire s est au liban
depuis dix jours
il a été chargé d'une mission d'urgence
je suis venu ici au liban pour acheter
des poches de sang et des médicaments
aujourd'hui j'ai reçu un appel de mes
amis à homme
ils m'ont dit que les forces de bachar
al assad ont détruit nos hôpitaux de
campagne
ils ont arrêté les médecins et cinq
blessés aussi un beau farès tente de
joindre par internet
un médecin de homs bonsoir comment ça va
ça va vous avez pu envoyer les poches de
sang
non on n'a rien pu faire hier soir et la
croix rouge elle n'a pas pu non plus
distribuer des poches de sang la radio
net
non c'était impossible mais qui êtes
vous fait quoi exactement
elle est journaliste
mais elle peut nous aider à faire
entendre notre voix au monde entier on a
besoin de tout montrer l'urgence
humanitaire dans cette série interdite
aux observateurs voilà ce qui peut
pousser à boffa rsa nous faire passer
illégalement la frontière
on se rapproche du lion se rapproche
audi vient qu'est ce que vous ressentez
je suis anxieux
la ville de homs moment
abu farès comme tous les jeunes
révolutionnaires syriens restent
connectés en permanence à internet
il réussit à déjouer la censure on a
créé cette carte pour déjouer les
checkpoints des miliciens d'assad
donc là on va passer aujourd'hui à
travers tous ces checkpoints
oui on va passer par là on réactualise
cette carte tous les jours
abu farès appelle le passeur je viens
d'arriver
où es tu
s'il est là c'est bon il nous attend
c'est encore loin
on est tout près nous ferons un arrêt
d'à peine une heure dans la maison du
passeur le temps pour moi d'enfiler des
vêtements syrien de prendre une caméra
plus discrète et de changer de véhicule
[Musique]
nous nous rapprochons un peu plus de la
frontière syrienne
notre passeur soit sur internet les
nouvelles en direct de la ville de homs
le siège de la vieille ville est en
cours
il y à des arrestations en masse 2000
soldats et miliciens du régime ont été
déployés
attention il y as barrage devant
devant nous deux opposants syriens à
moto vont nous aider à éviter les postes
de frontières et nous guider sur des
chemins de traverse
durant tout notre voyage nous seront
prises en charge par des éclaireurs vous
voyez les arbres là bas la syrie est
juste derrière
plus que quelques centaines de mètres
avant le point de passage
le territoire c'est rien ça y est on y
va en série on y va on y va
un talus à franchir et ça y est nous y
sommes
depuis quelques jours l'armée syrienne a
miné la frontière chaque pas est risqué
il faut marcher vite les positions
syriennes sont à 200 m dépêchez-vous il
arrive un peu plus loin d'autres motos
nous attendent
ce sont des déserteurs de l'armée
syrienne qui ont rejoint la contestation
nous ne la voyons pas mais l'armée de
bachar al assad est partout
toutes les trois minutes nos éclaireurs
se renseigne par téléphone sur les
positions des troupes
ils ont pour mission de nous mettre à
l'abri au plus vite
nous nous arrêtons à l'entrée d'un
village très vite nous sommes prise à
témoin par des hommes nous ne filmeront
pas leur visage
parlez à des médias occidentaux les
condamne à mort tue des femmes
il tue les enfants des innocents même
les blessés les achève pourquoi leurs
revendications sont sans appel tout ce
qu'ils veulent c'est la chute du
dictateur bachar partira avec la volonté
du peuple
il n'ya plus de retour en arrière
possible on s'est tu pendant 40 ans
aujourd'hui on n'a plus peur dans une
maison du village
un homme demande à me parler il se
présente comme un déserteur
il appartenait à une unité d'élite
réputée pour semer la terreur une unité
dirigée par le propre frère du président
il y a trois mois j'ai été mobilisé pour
aller tuer des groupes terroristes qui
tirait sur des gens j'ai été surpris
lorsque j'ai découvert que l'armée
m'envoyait dans mon propre village
mes supérieurs m'ont demandé de
disperser la manifestation et moi je me
disais où sont les terroristes
et puis je me suis retrouvé face à mon
frère
comment aurais-je pu nous tuer cette
manifestation était pacifique
il portait juste des banderoles qui
disaient à bas le régime
ce jour là j'ai jeté mon uniforme
un jeune brandit un tee shirt aux
couleurs de la syrie un pays où se
côtoient des musulmans sunnites
majoritaires les alaouites theshit et
des chrétiens la syrie n'appartient pas
à bachar al assad
la syrie et c'est tout le monde à toutes
les communautés
il n'est pas acceptable que 3500
personnes meurent pour que bachar reste
au pouvoir
merci beaucoup le vendredi jour de
prière est devenu jours de contestation
et les murs de cette mosquée relais
désormais le message de la révolte
ce jour là ils prient pour les morts de
la révolution devenu pour les martyrs
aujourd'hui nous prions pour la mémoire
des six personnes tuées au cours de la
dernière manifestation mais aussi pour
tous ceux qui sont tombés depuis le
début de la révolution sous bonne
escorte
nous rejoignons la manifestation
[Musique]
quelques centaines de personnes
bravaient l'interdiction de descendre
dans la rue
des images rares jusqu'à présent seuls
les téléphones portables réussissait à
filmer les manifestations
celle que le régime veut cacher au reste
du monde
le jeune homme qui m'avait donné son tee
shirt harangue la foule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans la foule des hommes de toutes les
générations
quelques femmes et au premier rang des
enfants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hier on nous a tiré dessus mais on ne
s'arrêtera jamais il faut que bachar
dégage brusquement la tension monte
il faut partir les forces de sécurité
approche la zone
ils ont mis en place un nouveau
checkpoint ils peuvent attaquer on ne
sait pas mais on est surpris qu'ils
aient installé ce checkpoint maintenant
vous pensez qu'ils ont appris qu'il y
avait des journalistes étrangers ici
peut-être on ne sait pas nous ne sommes
pas désirer ils ne veulent pas de
témoins bien sûr ils ne veulent qu aucun
témoin étrangers ne rentrer en syrie
ils veulent que personne dans le monde
ne sache ce qui se passe ici nos
accompagnateurs redoutent une action de
l'armée de bachar al assad et que ce
rassemblement ne se termine dans le sang
des blessés nous allons en voir dans un
hôpital de campagne
ceux qui le tiennent se revendiquent de
l'armée libre de syrie
c'est une maison transformée en centre
de soins
trois blessés nous sont présentées comme
des civils victimes des tirs de l'armée
syrienne
puis il a été touché par un tir de
sniper les gens syrie aujourd'hui ne
vont plus dans les hôpitaux
pourquoi qu'est ce qui peut se passer
dans les zones est chaud c'est simple
celui qui rentre à l'hôpital public avec
une balle dans la jambe ressort avec une
balle dans la tête
six hommes disent que les hôpitaux
clandestins sont des cibles de l'armée
syrienne qui en auraient détruit 10 la
veille
celui ci serait désormais le dernier de
la zone j'ai reçu six balles dans la
jambe dans mon ventre dans mon bras
on sortait de la mosquée c'était le
vendredi
des miliciens du régime et des soldats
sont arrivés ils nous ont tiré dessus
sans raison
il y avait des tireurs sur les toits
j'ai rampé derrière un arbre et des
jeunes sont venus me se courir cette
perfusion a pu être posée par un médecin
mais il ne vient plus trop dangereux ces
hommes disent que cinq médecins viennent
d'être arrêtés pour avoir soigné des
blessés dans la clandestinité
on est obligé de faire tout nous mêmes
on et infirmiers médecins
les médecins ne viennent plus ici on ne
peut pas laisser les blessés mourir
aucune formation et des médicaments qui
manquent
voici la trousse du soldat
c'est quoi ce qu'ils ont ok à me
souviens bactérienne antiseptique
c'est tout bon c'est tout ce que vous
avez
il faut déjà repartir
l'endroit n'est plus sécurisé au coeur
de la nuit
nous passons à 300 mètres des lignes de
l'armée régulière pour rejoindre un
groupe de soldats
ils viennent tout juste de déserter nous
sommes dans un des quartiers généraux de
ceux qui se proclament armée libre de
syrie il affirme être plus de 15000 un
nombre invérifiable la plupart de ces
hommes combattaient encore il ya
quelques semaines dans l'armée du régime
ils tiennent à nous montrer leurs armes
toutes celles qu'ils emportent avec eux
quand ils désertent et d'autres
peut-être haineux l'enfoncent pas
jusqu'au bout
vous en avez beaucoup comme ça on en a
beaucoup
combien coûte une centaine
elles viennent d'où des pays limitrophe
de la syrie
quel pays je ne veux pas dire les noms
de quel pays parlent et ils on n'en
saura pas plus l'officier est aussitôt
recadré par son supérieur
non non non non nous n'avons reçu aucune
arme de l'étranger ou de ces armes
on les a rapporté nous mêmes c'est notre
butin de guerre la preuve regardez ces
armes sont fabriqués en russie et c'est
la russie qui a toujours approvisionnés
la syrie en armes
mais notre arme fatale pour faire tomber
le régime
c'est ce rameau d'olivier seuls trois
déserteurs par le tas visage découvert
ils veulent nous prouver avec leur carte
militaire qu'ils étaient bien dans
l'armée de bachar al assad non on n'a
pas peur
si on avait peur on n'aurait pas déserté
mais on est inquiet pour nos familles
pour nos amis c'est ça le problème
on se sent mieux avant les gens nous
regardaient d'un mauvais oeil
ils nous détestent est aujourd'hui quand
ils nous voient ils sont fiers de nous
fin de la conversation il improvise une
mise en scène et profitent de notre
caméra pour lancer un message
nous demandons à la communauté
internationale une zone d'exclusion
aérienne est une intervention militaire
sans troupes sur le sol syrien
soudain un ordre tombe les jeunes
déserteurs sont envoyés dans la ville de
homs
tout juste encerclée par les forces de
bachar al assad vous allez où on va
défendre un quartier qui est assiégée où
ça dans la ville de homs
vous y allez tous oui on y va tous nous
avons de l'espoir
dieu est avec nous
nous aussi nous prenons la route pour un
nouveau lieu sûr toujours escortée par
deux jeunes motards qui veille sur notre
sécurité nous ne sommes plus qu'à 5 km
de homs
mais ce soir notre entrée dans la ville
est compromise les tanks barre le
passage
[Musique]
on n'est pas sûrs d'y aller ce soir
peut-être demain nous arrivons dans une
nouvelle cache c'est là que nous allons
passer la nuit quatre hommes en armes
veilleront sur nous la chaîne qatarie al
jazeera diffuse des images en direct des
manifestations à homs
[Applaudissements]
vous avez envie d'y être
bien sûr que j'ai envie d'y être je
manifestais tous les jours et là ça fait
dix jours que je n'ai pas manifester
demain demain inch'allah brusquement
dans la pièce d'à côté
abdallah qui nous assurent notre
sécurité semble inquiet il a été informé
d'un mouvement de troupes
ils sont entrés dans le village où nous
étions ce matin comme d'habitude ils
vont arrêter les gens ont les tuer s'ils
font le sale boulot
qu'est ce qu'ils font ils tuent les gens
ont comme des chiens ils sont payés pour
sa part l'armée libre
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ils ont su que
l'armée libre était parti sur le front
de homs alors ils en profitent
entrée ne restez pas dehors toute la
nuit nous serons sur le qui vive
nous ne sommes qu'à trois kilomètres des
opérations de l'armée de bachar al assad
alors on va oms aujourd'hui au revoir
merci beaucoup
à bientôt c'est la dernière fois que je
verrai le lieutenant abdallah qui
assurer notre sécurité depuis le début
du voyage
il sera tué quelques jours après notre
départ de syrie avec six de ses hommes
allez-y on vous ouvre la route
mais sur la route de homs nous allons
devoir de nouveau nous arrêter à
quelques mètres de nous des convois de
l'armée syrienne sont en route vers la
ville c'est la première et dernière fois
que nous verrons les tempes de bachar al
assad
il y à un tank qui bloquent le passage
qu'on voulait prendre donc on va
traverser par un autre endroit mais
juste sous les yeux des soldats qui
gardent le barrage donc on va se séparer
en deux groupes
on vous suit
ok donc si je comprends bien l'armée
syrienne est juste de l'autre côté de la
route
oui oui nous traversons une autoroute
nous parvenons à filmer quelques images
avec un téléphone portable
de l'autre côté nous sommes accueillis
par un des hommes qui contrôle la zone
et nous fait monter dans sa voiture
[Musique]
à l'aller
j
dieu merci on a réussi à passer regarde
regarde il ya un char là bas et là il y
en a un autre
[Applaudissements]
qui nous entendons les premiers tirs
nous sommes près de la ligne de front
dans le quartier de baba à marquis
launay depuis plusieurs semaines par
l'armée syrienne
faut qu'on se dépêche faut pas rester
ici vous êtes allé quand traverser le
quartier de baba amr et très dangereux
mais c'est la seule voie pour entrer
dans la ville de homs
l'homme qui conduit connaît toutes les
caches des tireurs embusqués c'est très
dangereux de rester ici
mais regardez les gens du quartier sont
tellement courageux ils montent la garde
devant leur maison
parce que quand les miliciens rentrent
ils pillent tout nous laissons les tirs
derrière nous pour arriver à homs
la première chose que je vois ce sont
ces slogans de la révolution sur les
murs abu farès retrouve sa ville cela
oui maintenant ça y est je me sentais
mieux oui je me sens libre dans une
ville occupée impression étrange de voir
dans les rues de cette ville assiégée
comme une apparence de vie normale débat
sans des écoliers
[Musique]
là c'était mon école abu farès veut nous
faire rencontrer les victimes de la
répression
les lieux ne doivent pas être identifiés
il nous présente un adolescent blessé
par balle
mounir à 16 ans tu penses qu'ils t'ont
visé intentionnellement
ça s'est passé dans une manifestation
ils sont arrivés et ils ont commencé à
tirer
il y avait une petite fille qui marchait
à côté de moi j'ai voulu la protéger
c'est là que j'ai été touché elle a été
abattue à laver six ans
votre tuyau qu'est ce qui arriva la
balle est entrée par là elle a touché le
système nerveux
elle est ressortie par le dos à cet
endroit tout ça
trip j'ai reçu trois balles les deux
autres sont entrés par là
si tu as vu un médecin quand j'ai été
blessé on m'a emmené à l'hôpital mais
après les miliciens du régime ont
attaqué l'hôpital et ils ont arrêté 41
blessés ils ont arrêté 41 blessés dans
l'hôpital des blessés
j'ai réussi à m'enfuir
ils prennent les blessés pour qu'on les
soigne pas pour qu'il ne survive pas
nous allons dans un autre quartier de
homs
dans le sous sol d'un immeuble c'est
maintenant le témoignage d'une mère d'un
petit garçon de trois ans que je vais
recueillir
il a reçu une balle à cet endroit et
elle est ressortie par la la c'est la
cicatrice de l'opération là on lui a
installé une sonde parce qu'il avait des
éclats de balles dans l'intestin
c'est comme vivre dans la guerre oui
c'est une guerre il faut que le régime
tombe très vite pour que notre vie
s'améliore mon mari ne va plus au
travail
il ne sort plus de la maison il y à des
barrages partout il peut se faire
arrêter à tout moment quand on sort on
n'est jamais certain de revenir
maintenant monfils est terrorisée je lui
dit ne pleure pas ne pleure pas je le
console et parfois il s'endort
mise en confiance elle accepte de nous
emmener dans l'appartement familial elle
nous présente sa fille aînée elle a 5
ans elle est devenue en huit mois une
enfant de la guerre on ne va plus jouer
au parc
parce qu'ils tirent des bombes sur nos
têtes et si on y va
ils nous tirent dessus avec une balle ma
copine on lui a tiré dessus et on lui a
coupé la jambe ici en dessous du genou
on lui a coupé comme ça elle demande à
sa maman maman quand est-ce qu'elle va
repousser ma jambe
[Musique]
elle est gentille
quand elle marche elle fait comme ça
quand elle marche comme ça elle attend
une nouvelle jambe mais sa jambe elle
n'est toujours pas venu dans la nuit le
quartier de baba ammar a de nouveau été
bombardées
nous décidons d'y retourner regardez cet
immeuble a été bombardé hier même les
écoles ils ne les ont pas épargnés
[Musique]
je passe devant un cimetière aujourd'hui
ici il serait même devenu dangereux
d'enterrer ses morts
on essaye de regrouper tous les corps
dans un même lieu pour les enterrer mais
ceux qui sont morts hier à baba a marre
on n'a pas pu ramasser leurs corps parce
que les bombardements ont été très
intenses sont en dentaire quelqu'un on
le fait seulement à quatre personnes
si on est plus ils nous tirent dessus
c'est notre dernier soir en syrie abu
farès nous emmène à une manifestation
l'une de celle qu'il attendait depuis
dix jours dans tous les quartiers de
homs
des milliers de personnes se rassemblent
dans une ambiance de fête
c'est incroyable quand on a commencé
notre révolution on ne s'attendait pas à
un tel succès on était les premiers
surpris mais on était sûr de notre cause
maintenant jour après jour on sent qu'on
se rapproche de la victoire de la
liberté pour tout le peuple syrien
mais comme presque toujours en syrie la
manifestation va s'achever sous les tirs
[Applaudissements]
ils peuvent nous tuer avec leurs balles
mais il ne tueront jamais notre rêve de
liberté
je repars de syrie avec le sentiment
qu'ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
partager ce rêve de liberté à défier
sans relâche la terreur
[Applaudissements]